My name is Miranda Cheng and I do research
here in the University of Amsterdam on the
boundary between physics and mathematics.
I use mathematics to study the physical properties
of various systems.
And, in the other direction, I use physical
insights to try to think about mathematical
questions.
Umbral moonshine is a fascinating relation
between finites groups on the one hand and
mock modular forms on the other hand.
Finite groups are structres capturing the
symmetry properties of various subjects.
So, repeating systems and patterns in 24 dimensions
in this case.
And mock modular forms?
Well, they’re really cute functions displaying
very funny properties under modular transformation,
and in the meanwhile they have been found
to have relations to other branches of mathematics
such as combinatorics and so on.
And what I hope umbral moonshine can teach
us?
Well, the most exciting prospect for me is
the following: I hope it will open a
window for us into some fundamental aspects
of string theory, which is a theory that we
believe to capture the physics at the most
fundamental level in our world.
In particular, I hope that it will teach us
something about how quantum states allow by supersymmetry
can organize themselves in a specific way.